144 migrantes pudieron desembarcar del
humanity 1 el barco humanitario que
llegó este sábado casi a medianoche al
puerto de catania en la isla italiana de
sicilia con abordo 179 migrantes
rescatados en el mar Mediterráneo por la
ong alemana sos humanity funcionarios
del ministerio italiano del interior
inspeccionaron el barco a su llegada y
evaluaron las condiciones de cada una de
las personas a bordo y así varias
decenas de menores tres mujeres un bebé
y varios enfermos pudieron pisar
finalmente en la Tierra Firme los demás
migrantes a bordo del barco no fueron
autorizados a salir 35 hombres adultos
quedaron así bloqueados a bordo según
personal de la ong a bordo estas
personas se encuentran en un estado de
fuerte ansiedad han sufrido el trauma de
un periplo tremendo y según ellos es
ilegal no dejarlos desembarcar a pesar
de esto el gobierno italiano no parece
intencionado a ceder el nuevo ejecutivo
de ultraderecha italiano exige que estos
35 migrantes sean acogidos por el país
de origen del barco humanitario es decir
Alemania por el momento el barco
permanece bloqueado en el puerto pero
podría recibir en las próximas horas la
orden de salir de las aguas
territoriales de Italia